It's a simple story. Cain kills Abel. God comes around and asks him, where's your brother? He replies, am I my brother's keeper? Then God punishes him for what he's done. If there's a lesson in here about how we're supposed to treat each other, and look out for each other. The lesson is so broad that it's almost useless.
这是一个简单的故事。该隐杀了亚伯。上帝走过来问他，你弟弟在哪里？他回答说，我难道是我弟弟的看守吗？然后上帝因为他所做的事惩罚了他。如果这里面有什么关于我们应该如何对待彼此、如何关照彼此的教训的话，这个教训太宽泛了，几乎毫无用处。
Yes, it says, you are your brother's keeper, to the extent that you shouldn't actually murder your own brother. It's not until later in the Bible that you get into more practical, everyday kind of instructions. To lend your neighbors money in hard times. Give them a place to stay if they need it. To love your neighbor as yourself.
是的，它说，你确实是你弟弟的看守，程度是你实际上不应该谋杀你自己的亲兄弟。直到圣经的后期，你才会接触到更实用、更日常的指示。在困难时期借钱给邻居。如果他们需要，给他们一个住处。爱邻如己。
The story of Cain and Abel is kind of a blunt instrument. A guy misjudges what he should do. And then someone dies. It's the first death in the Bible. Abel is the first person to die. And it's because his brother screwed up.
该隐和亚伯的故事就像一把钝器。一个人误判了他应该做的事。然后有人死了。这是圣经中的第一次死亡。亚伯是第一个死去的人。而这正是因为他哥哥搞砸了。
But today on our program we have three stories of people trying to figure out how to treat their brothers, and their neighbors, and whether they should step in to help. Trying to figure out if stepping in would do anyone any good at all. WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Brother's Keeper. Biblical stories ripped from the day's headlines.
但今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个关于人们试图找出如何对待他们的兄弟、他们的邻居，以及是否应该介入帮忙的故事。试图弄清楚介入是否真的对任何人有好处。WBEZ芝加哥，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，《兄弟的看守》。取自每日头条新闻的圣经故事。
Act One, Whatever Happened to Baby Cain? In that act, Jonathan Goldstein re-tells the story of Cain and Abel. Finally, we get to hear Cain's side of things.
第一幕，小该隐怎么了？在那一幕中，乔纳森·戈德斯坦重述了该隐和亚伯的故事。最终，我们听到了该隐这一方的说法。
Act Two, This Land Is Your Land, This Land Is My Land. Or Maybe Not. We hear the story of somebody trying to help all sorts of people who absolutely do not want his help.
第二幕，这片土地是你的土地，这片土地是我的土地。或者也许不是。我们听到了一个人试图帮助所有那些绝对不想要他帮助的人的故事。
Act Three, Neighbor's Keeper. In that act, could anyone in a small farming town have done anything to prevent a brutal crime committed by one of their neighbors. Stay with us.
第三幕，邻居的看守。在那一幕中，一个小农镇里的任何人是否本可以采取任何行动来阻止他们邻居犯下的残忍罪行。请继续关注我们。
Whatever Happened to Baby Cain?
小该隐怎么了？
One of our contributing editors here at This American Life, Jonathan Goldstein, has taken on as his latest project rewriting the Bible. Regular listeners to our show may remember his retelling of the story of Adam and Eve a few months back. To tell this story of Cain and Abel, he pretty much picks up the tale where he left off.
《美国生活》的特约编辑之一乔纳森·戈德斯坦，将重写《圣经》作为他最新的项目。我们节目的忠实听众可能还记得几个月前他重述亚当和夏娃的故事。为了讲述这个该隐和亚伯的故事，他基本上是从他上次中断的地方接着讲。
On their first night outside the Garden of Eden, it was windy and cold, and the air was full of whistling. They scraped at the tree trunks, and dug their fingers into the earth. At the top of their voices, Adam and Eve called out to God. We get it, they screamed. You've made your point.
在伊甸园外的第一个夜晚，风很大，天气很冷，空气中充满了呼啸声。他们刮擦着树干，用手指挖着泥土。亚当和夏娃用尽全身力气呼唤上帝。我们明白了，他们尖叫道。你已经表达了你的观点。
To fend off the cold, they hugged each other with all of their might. They thought about all of the things God had said in his wrath. How a little human would one day tear his way out of Eve. How they would no longer live forever, but would one day die. These thoughts made them colder. They slept face to face, pressed so tightly together, that the bones in their noses hurt. Later, they would learn to make clothing. But just then, all they had was each other. Nine months after that first night, this would change.
为了抵御寒冷，他们竭尽全力紧紧拥抱在一起。他们想到了上帝在愤怒中所说的一切。一个小人有一天会如何从夏娃体内挣脱出来。他们将不再永生，而是有一天会死去。这些想法让他们感到更冷。他们面对面睡着，紧紧贴在一起，连鼻梁骨都感到疼痛。后来，他们学会了制作衣服。但就在那时，他们唯一拥有的只有彼此。那第一个夜晚九个月后，这一切将发生改变。
In the beginning, in the garden, the baby was supposed to be a surprise, appearing as suddenly as a sneeze. The way God intended it, two people in love would share a like-minded pretty thought. And there it would be, a baby nesting in a tree above their heads. But the way God intended it, did not pan out.
起初，在花园里，婴儿本应该是一个惊喜，像喷嚏一样突然出现。按照上帝的意愿，两个相爱的人会分享一个志趣相投的美好想法。然后它就会在那里，一个婴儿在他们头顶上方的树中筑巢。但上帝的意愿并没有实现。
On the night their child was born, Eve was asleep, dreaming about the ocean. She was swimming beneath it, breathing in the water like it was air. Very carefully, she climbed onto a shark, and rode him. I am actually doing it, she thought. Then the shark turned and bit off her lower body. Eve awoke suddenly. She had begun to give birth.
在孩子出生的那个晚上，夏娃睡着了，梦见了海洋。她在海面下游泳，像呼吸空气一样呼吸着海水。她非常小心地爬上一条鲨鱼，骑在它身上。我真的做到了，她想。然后鲨鱼转过身，咬掉了她的下半身。夏娃突然惊醒。她已经开始分娩了。
Adam hopped from foot to foot as Eve felt the pain crush her into the earth. Yes, this was the baby, and the baby was attached to a vine. After a few days, despite their great care, the vine wore away, and baby Cain was freed into the world.
亚当手足无措地跳着，夏娃感到疼痛将她压入大地。是的，这就是婴儿，而且婴儿连着一根藤蔓。几天后，尽管他们非常小心，藤蔓还是磨损了，婴儿该隐被释放到了这个世界上。
At the time of her second birth, there wasn't the same stage fright. Eve knew the drill. She laid herself on the ground, and grabbed two fistfuls of grass. Six and a half hours later, Abel was born. They called Cain over to meet his new brother. They placed the baby in his arms. The baby was slippery, and Cain lost his grip. Abel fell. He lay on the ground, looking up at his brother. He did not cry. Abel could not be rattled.
在第二次分娩时，没有了同样的舞台恐惧。夏娃知道流程。她躺在地上，抓了两把草。六个半小时后，亚伯出生了。他们叫该隐过来见他的新弟弟。他们把婴儿放在他的怀里。婴儿很滑，该隐没抓住。亚伯摔倒了。他躺在地上，抬头看着他的哥哥。他没有哭。亚伯不会被吓倒。
Back in those first days, things changed very quickly. A new person being born meant there was a giant spike in the population. For Cain, it made the planet feel lopsided. He watched Eve bounce the newborn in her lap, and as she cooed at it, he felt the earth's gravity tilt in their direction. It pulled at the insides of his stomach, and made him sea-sick.
在最初的那几天里，事情变化很快。一个新人的诞生意味着人口出现了巨大的激增。对于该隐来说，这让地球感觉倾斜了。他看着夏娃在膝盖上摇晃新生儿，当她对着它咕咕叫时，他感到地球的引力向他们那边倾斜。它拉扯着他胃里的内脏，让他晕船。
Years later, Adam and Eve would have many more children. But just then, there was only Cain and Abel. Because there was simply nobody else, the brothers became very close. They invented their own language and played each other's stomachs like snare drums. They butted their heads like goats, and cracked each other's knuckles as though they were cracking their own.
多年后，亚当和夏娃又有了许多孩子。但当时，只有该隐和亚伯。因为根本没有其他人，兄弟俩变得非常亲近。他们发明了自己的语言，像小鼓一样敲打对方的肚子。他们像山羊一样抵头，像掰自己的指关节一样掰对方的指关节。
They were different, though. Abel was a thinker. He thought about things. If he bit off his own pinky toe, would it grow back? Cain on the other hand was a doer. He'd reel back his fist and break a donkey's nose for the sheer thrill of it all.
不过他们很不一样。亚伯是个思考者。他会思考事情。如果他咬掉自己的小脚趾，它会长回来吗？而该隐是个实干家。他会向后挥拳，为了那种纯粹的快感而打断一头驴的鼻子。
One day, when Adam and Eve thought the children were old enough, they sat them down and told the story of what life was like before they were born. "In those days, God was like one of the family," said Adam. Eve told Cain and Abel about the screw-up. "What does it mean to die?", asked Cain. "We're not exactly sure," said Eve. "But basically, it means that one day-- and this is not any day soon-- we will no longer be. "
有一天，当亚当和夏娃认为孩子们已经长大了，他们让他们坐下，讲述了他们出生前生活是什么样子的故事。“在那些日子里，上帝就像家庭的一员，”亚当说。夏娃向该隐和亚伯讲述了那次搞砸的事。“死亡是什么意思？”，该隐问。“我们不太确定，”夏娃说。“但基本上，这意味着有一天——而且这不是很快就会发生的一天——我们将不再存在。”
There was a silence. Then Abel spoke up. "If we won't be," he said, "then we won't even know that we're not being. There will be no we to see that we can no longer be."
一阵沉默。然后亚伯开口了。“如果我们不再存在，”他说，“那么我们甚至不会知道我们不存在了。不会有‘我们’去看到我们已不再存在。”
"Yes, I guess that's true," said their mother. "Well put." Abel smiled and went back to mashing a mutton liver, which he was making into pate for later. Cain on the other hand, felt like a sharp plum pit had been forcefully lodged down his throat. All his life, he had felt like himself. That his hands and fingers, that his thoughts, were his own. Now he felt like they were someone else's. Someone who could yank them away at any chosen moment. Until then, it had never crossed his mind that such a thing could be possible.
“是的，我想那是真的，”他们的母亲说。“说得好。”亚伯笑了笑，又回去捣羊肝，那是他为稍后制作的馅饼准备的。另一方面，该隐觉得好像一颗锋利的李子核被强行塞进了他的喉咙。他一生都觉得他就是他自己。他的手和手指，他的思想，都是他自己的。现在他觉得它们是别人的了。一个可以在任何时候把它们夺走的人。在那之前，他从未想过这样的事情是可能的。
The brothers continued to live their lives. But all the while, Cain felt a new sadness. It was there all the time. It ate with him, worked with him, and in the morning it raised from his bed with him. Dying. It just didn't make any sense. He knew this deep in his heart. He thought nothing was more important than making God change his mind. Nothing.
兄弟俩继续过着他们的生活。但一直以来，该隐感到一种新的悲伤。它一直都在。它和他一起吃饭，一起工作，早上和他一起从床上起来。死亡。这根本说不通。他内心深处明白这一点。他认为没有什么比让上帝改变主意更重要的了。没有什么。
He began to take his sacrifices more seriously. They became elaborate and garish. They involved richly choreographed interpretive dances, colorful oblong facial masks, and the very best of his legumes. But God never answered.
他开始更认真地对待他的祭品。它们变得复杂而华丽。它们涉及精心编排的现代舞、色彩鲜艳的长方形面具，以及他最好的豆类。但上帝从不回应。
Cain started to change. When he got a splinter, he cursed the heavens all out of proportion. "Back in the garden of Eden, there were no splinters," Cain said to Abel. "Instead of splinters, they had trees that sprouted [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and home fries." He even started to resent his parents. He spoke of them as though they had gambled away his inheritance.
该隐开始改变。当他被木刺扎到时，他会以不成比例的方式诅咒上天。“回到伊甸园时，没有木刺，”该隐对亚伯说。“取而代之的是，他们有长出[无法理解]和薯条的树。”他甚至开始怨恨他的父母。他谈论他们时，就好像他们赌掉了他的遗产一样。
"If it hadn't have been for Ignoramus number one, tempting Ignoramus number two, we'd be living in luxury." Cain tried to get Able all worked up about the whole thing too. But Abel had an easy come, easy go, we all have to die someday attitude. That drove his brother crazy. As long as he had his sheep, as long as he could rub his naked feet through their wool, Abel felt that things were really not so bad.
“如果不是一号傻瓜诱惑了二号傻瓜，我们现在就会生活在奢华之中。”该隐也试图让亚伯对这一切感到激动。但亚伯有一种随遇而安、我们总有一天会死的心态。这让他的哥哥发疯。只要他有他的羊，只要他能用赤脚摩擦它们的羊毛，亚伯就觉得事情其实没那么糟糕。
Cain invented a game he called, Get the Hell Out of Eden. He always insisted on playing God. "Get your naked asses out of here," yelled God. "What? But we just got here!", yelled Adam and Eve. "Maybe there's some kind of mistake."
该隐发明了一个游戏，他称之为“滚出伊甸园”。他总是坚持扮演上帝。“滚出这里，你们这些赤身裸体的家伙，”上帝大喊。“什么？但我们才刚到这里！”，亚当和夏娃喊道。“也许是个误会。”
"The Lord does not make mistakes." God would then kick his brother in the ass. He would fall to the ground and, holding his ass say, "Please, please have mercy on me. Let's play something else." And God would laugh.
“主不会犯错。”然后上帝会踢他哥哥的屁股。他会倒在地上，捂着屁股说：“请，请怜悯我。我们玩点别的吧。”上帝就会大笑。
Now that he was older, every week Abel would choose the fattest, firstborn sheep, and sacrifice them to God. Everything Abel did in life was for a reason. He ate so that he would not be hungry. He made clothes so that he would not be cold. But making sacrifices to God, he did it for reasons he could never know. He did it simply because he was told to. There was something about that, that made him feel clean and deep.
现在他长大了，亚伯每周都会挑选最肥的头生羊，献祭给上帝。亚伯生活中的一切都是有原因的。他吃饭是为了不饿。他做衣服是为了不冷。但向上帝献祭，他这么做是因为他永远无法知晓的原因。他只是因为被告知要这样做而这样做。这其中有什么东西，让他感到纯洁和深沉。
Adam and Eve made the sacrifices out of fear of being further punished. And Cain was pleading for answers and changes. But Abel fulfilled his obligation, and walked away expecting nothing from God. He was glad with the way things were. And God could not have helped liking that.
亚当和夏娃因为害怕进一步受到惩罚而献祭。该隐则在恳求答案和改变。但亚伯履行了他的义务，离开时没有期望从上帝那里得到任何东西。他对现状感到满意。上帝不可能不喜欢那样。
Meanwhile, Cain decided to test out a new approach with the Lord. He believed that God would have greater respect for him if he did not kowtow. "He's going to kill us," he thought. He wanted God to understand that he couldn't walk all over people, and then still have them come crawling back with their arms loaded up with gifts. No. They had to get tough. So Cain's sacrifices became more and more lackadaisical. He did not even check to see whether his gifts were being received or not. That would look like he was caving.
与此同时，该隐决定尝试一种对待主的新方法。他认为如果他不卑躬屈膝，上帝会对他有更多的尊重。“他会杀了我们，”他想。他想让上帝明白，他不能践踏别人，然后还能让他们带着满怀的礼物爬回来。不。他们必须强硬起来。所以该隐的祭品变得越来越敷衍了事。他甚至不检查他的礼物是否被接受了。那看起来就像他在屈服。
Then one day, while Cain was lying in a field, Abel came running over. "God spoke to me," cried Abel. Cain shut up and looked at his brother. "What did he say?"
然后有一天，当该隐躺在田野里时，亚伯跑了过来。“上帝对我说话了，”亚伯喊道。该隐闭嘴看着他的弟弟。“他说了什么？”
"He said he was a great fan of my sheep. He told me to keep up the good work." "Was my name mentioned?", asked Cain. "It didn't come up."
“他说他是我的羊的忠实粉丝。他告诉我保持良好的工作。”“提到我的名字了吗？”，该隐问。“没提。”
"What was it like to hear his voice?," asked Cain. "Look at me," said Abel. "I'm still shaking."
“听到他的声音是什么感觉？”，该隐问。“看着我，”亚伯说。“我还在发抖。”
There's was a certain pang that Cain started to feel a lot. It was in his stomach. He felt the pang grow sharpest when he looked upon his brother. He could hardly speak with him without having to hunch over in pain. Since the world was still new, and no one had yet felt this way, Cain did not know that it was jealousy he was feeling.
该隐开始频繁感到一种刺痛。在胃里。当他看着他的弟弟时，他感到这种刺痛最剧烈。他几乎无法与他交谈而不因痛苦而弯下腰。由于世界仍然是新的，还没有人有过这种感觉，该隐不知道他感到的正是嫉妒。
Instead, he decided that his stomach no longer wanted to be his stomach. It wanted to escape his rib cage. It wanted to be Abel's stomach. This was because he wanted to be Abel. There was no shame in this. Being Abel meant being happy. Being Cain meant being wretched. Being Cain had brought him nothing.
相反，他决定他的胃不再想成为他的胃了。它想逃出他的胸腔。它想成为亚伯的胃。这是因为他想成为亚伯。这并不丢人。成为亚伯意味着快乐。成为该隐意味着悲惨。成为该隐没有给他带来任何东西。
He had a plan. He approached Abel with it. He decided to just spring it on him. "I am no longer Cain," said Cain. "I am now Abel. We are both Abel." "All right," said Abel.
他有一个计划。他带着计划接近亚伯。他决定突然告诉他。“我不再是该隐了，”该隐说。“我现在是亚伯。我们都是亚伯。”“好吧，”亚伯说。
The two Abels performed routines for the amusement of their brothers and sisters. "How's that apple, Abel?" "It's fine, Abel." "Abel, could you pass it over so that I may have a bite?" "I, Abel, don't see why not, Abel." Then one day, things became more grave. "If I am Abel," said Cain, "then I am just as much Abel as you yourself are Abel."
两个亚伯为他们的兄弟姐妹表演节目来娱乐他们。“那个苹果怎么样，亚伯？”“很好，亚伯。”“亚伯，你能递过来让我咬一口吗？”“我，亚伯，看不出为什么不，亚伯。”然后有一天，事情变得更加严重。“如果我是亚伯，”该隐说，“那么我和你一样都是亚伯。”
"I suppose that's true," said Abel. "Then before God, are we not both Abel?", asked Cain. "Well, in the case of being before God, I think at that time, I would be Abel, and you would go back to being Cain." "That won't do," said Cain. His eyes lingered on his brother. He looked at this other Abel as standing in the way of who he was.
“我想那是真的，”亚伯说。“那么在上帝面前，我们难道不都是亚伯吗？”，该隐问。“嗯，如果是站在上帝面前，我想在那个时候，我会是亚伯，而你会变回该隐。”“那不行，”该隐说。他的目光停留在他的弟弟身上。他看着这个“亚伯”站在他成为他自己的道路上。
He was Abel. He knew this in his heart. He simply wanted it more. This way, God would have to show himself. This way, God would have to stop playing possum and get directly involved in what was going on. These were Cain's thoughts.
他就是亚伯。他内心深处知道这一点。他只是更想要它。这样，上帝就必须显现自己。这样，上帝就必须停止装死，直接参与到正在发生的事情中来。这些是该隐的想法。
Abel was among his flock when Cain neared him. Slowly, Cain pulled out his stick, and slowly, he lifted it into the air. Still though, there was no sign of God. He looked at the back of Abel's head. Then he looked into the sky. Just in case God was reading his mind, he thought to himself, "I'm really, really going to do it." He brought his stick down onto his brother's head. He could hear no sound at all. Abel just toppled over. He toppled over the way he did everything, with an easygoing acceptance. He sank to the earth as though thinking, "I must fall, so I will fall. I am falling. I have fallen."
亚伯在羊群中时，该隐靠近了他。该隐慢慢掏出他的棍子，慢慢地举到空中。尽管如此，还是没有上帝的迹象。他看着亚伯的后脑勺。然后他看向天空。为了以防万一上帝在读他的心思，他在心里想：“我真的，真的要动手了。”他把棍子重重地打在弟弟的头上。他听不到任何声音。亚伯只是倒下了。他倒下的方式和他做任何事的方式一样，带着随遇而安的接受。他沉向大地，仿佛在想：“我必须倒下，所以我倒下。我正在倒下。我已经倒下了。”
Cain grabbed his brother by the shoulder and turned him over. His brother's eyes were wide open. It was like Abel was looking past him, over his shoulder and up into the sky.
该隐抓住他弟弟的肩膀，把他翻过来。他弟弟的眼睛睁得大大的。就像亚伯在看着他身后，越过他的肩膀向上看向天空一样。
When they were kids, there was a game they played, where Cain would do something, something bad, and Abel would look over just behind him. As though spying their father, who had been watching. Cain, full of fear, would slowly turn to meet his father's gaze. When he'd see that there was really no one there, he would laugh. Now, it was like Abel was playing at their game, but this time, he did not move a muscle even to smile.
当他们还是孩子的时候，他们玩过一个游戏，该隐会做些什么，一些坏事，而亚伯会看向他身后。好像在窥探他们的父亲，他在看着。该隐，充满恐惧，会慢慢转过身去面对父亲的目光。当他看到真的没有人时，他会大笑。现在，就像亚伯在玩他们的游戏，但这一次，他连肌肉都没动一下，连微笑都没有。
Here it was. Death. Cain couldn't believe it. He'd been sure that at the last moment, God would step in. He would have thought that only God could have taken a person's life. But it was as simple as killing a sheep. Abel, his eyes wide and unblinking, stared directly into the mystery of life and death. And he was not saying a word about any of it.
这就是它。死亡。该隐简直不敢相信。他一直确信在最后一刻，上帝会介入。他本以为只有上帝才能夺走一个人的生命。但它就像杀一只羊一样简单。亚伯，他眼睛睁得大大的，一眨不眨，直视着生命与死亡的奥秘。而他对此一言不发。
Cain sat back and weighed it. The sheep continue to graze, and the sun continued to shine. There were no bolts of lightning, no booming voice from behind the clouds. Life went on. That night, God appeared before Cain in a dream. "Where is your brother?", asked God. "It's always about my brother," said Cain. "Do you ever ask me where I am? No, that you don't think of."
该隐坐下来权衡了一下。羊群继续吃草，太阳继续照耀。没有闪电，没有来自云后隆隆的声音。生活还在继续。那天晚上，上帝在梦中出现在该隐面前。“你弟弟在哪里？”，上帝问。“总是在问我弟弟，”该隐说。“你有没有问过我你在哪里？不，你没想到。”
"What have you done?", asked God. "Your brother's blood cries out to me from the ground." "Am I my brother's keeper?", asked Cain. God did not answer. He just gave him a look. It made Cain feel naked and small. He then felt the finger of God upon his forehead. It sank through his head and into his brain, where it spoke.
“你做了什么？”，上帝问。“你弟弟的血从地里向我哀告。”“我难道是我弟弟的看守吗？”，该隐问。上帝没有回答。他只是看了他一眼。这让该隐感到赤身裸体、渺小。然后他感到上帝的手指放在他的额头上。它穿过他的头进入他的大脑，在那里说话。
"The earth shall scorn you," said the voice from the finger. "I shall scorn you. You will wander the earth, and death will not come. There will be no escape from your guilt. All will look upon you, and none will dare kill you. For they will know you by your mark." God withdrew his finger, leaving behind a fingerprint on Cain's forehead that was shaped like a tear drop.
“大地必蔑视你，”手指发出的声音说。“我必蔑视你。你将流浪地球，而死亡不会到来。你将无法逃脱你的内疚。所有人都会注视你，却没人敢杀你。因为他们会通过你的标记认识你。”上帝收回了手指，在该隐的额头上留下了一个水滴形状的指纹。
At first he tried to convince himself that the mark was to protect him. That he had a secret pact with God. That they understood each other. For a while, he would wake up in the morning and pretend to be immortal and famous. But he was not very good at pretending. So as the centuries passed, Cain abandoned farming and roamed the earth. He walked with a sense of purpose, just in case anyone was watching. But in his heart, he knew he had nowhere to go.
起初，他试图说服自己，这个标记是为了保护他。他与上帝有一个秘密盟约。他们互相理解。有一段时间，他早上醒来，假装自己是不朽且著名的。但他并不擅长伪装。所以随着世纪流逝，该隐放弃了耕种，在地球上流浪。他带着一种目的感行走，以防有人在看。但在内心深处，他知道自己无处可去。
He became so lonely and full of regret, that instead of fearing death, he became yearnful of it. He would chase after bears, and they would scamper away. "They haven't the balls," he'd say. "Run, you little bitches," he'd call after the tigers. "Run, you yellow turds," he'd cry into the face of an alligator, as he tried in vain to pry open its jaws.
他变得如此孤独且充满悔恨，以至于他不仅不害怕死亡，反而渴望它。他会去追逐熊，它们却跑开了。“它们没种，”他说。“跑吧，你们这些小婊子，”他对着老虎喊道。“跑吧，你们这些黄色的粪便，”他对着鳄鱼的脸尖叫，试图徒劳地撬开它的下巴。
More centuries passed. And Cain's desire for death became nearly constant. He would think about Abel up in heaven, palling around with God, flying through the clouds on God's shoulders, while he was left to putz around for hundreds of years, begging his own children to drive tree branches through his heart. In life, Cain had been jealous of his brother. But it was in death, that he became more jealous than he ever thought was possible.
又几个世纪过去了。该隐对死亡的渴望变得几乎恒定。他会想到亚伯在天堂，和上帝交朋友，在上帝的肩上飞过云层，而他却被留下在世上游荡了几百年，乞求他自己的孩子把树枝插进他的心脏。生前，该隐嫉妒他的弟弟。但在死后，他变得比他曾经想象的任何时候都更嫉妒。
He could feel Abel up there looking down on him. "You should see the look on your face," he would hear his brother say, trying to be all serious. "You look like a gorilla."
他能感觉到亚伯在上面看着他。“你应该看看你脸上的表情，”他会听到他弟弟说，试图表现得很严肃。“你看上去像只大猩猩。”
Over time, Cain could no longer remember very much at all. 20 years after the death of his brother, it seemed like it was only yesterday. But after 200 years, it felt like something that might have happened in a dream. There were details he remembered, that now seemed improbable. Like the way he saw his brother's soul leave his body. And the way he'd waved goodbye to him, and winked.
随着时间的推移，该隐几乎什么都记不起来了。弟弟死后20年，感觉就像发生在昨天。但在200年后，感觉就像梦里发生的事。有些细节他还记得，但现在看起来不太可能。比如他看到弟弟的灵魂离开身体的样子。还有他向他挥手告别，并眨眼的样子。
After 300 and 400 years, it all felt so long ago, that who he was back then felt like someone else. When people he met asked him questions about the old days, he just made stuff up. "We had wings," he said.
300和400年后，这一切都感觉太久远了，以至于那时他是谁感觉像别人一样。当他遇到的人问他关于过去的日子的问题时，他只是编造。 “我们有翅膀，”他说。
After 500 years, his story was repeated so often, that he only remembered the repeating, not the events themselves. It sounded like a fable. Something that might have just as easily happened to a fox and a rabbit, as to himself and his brother. He began to doubt everything. He even began to wonder whether he had actually ever heard God's voice. Whether the mark on his forehead was the mark of God, and not just another liver spot.
500年后，他的故事被重复了太多次，以至于他只记得重复，而不是事件本身。它听起来像是一个寓言。一件既可能发生在狐狸和兔子身上，也可能发生在自己和弟弟身上的事情。他开始怀疑一切。他甚至开始怀疑自己是否真的听过上帝的声音。额头上的标记是否真的是上帝的标记，而不只是另一个肝斑。
"Was this a part of the punishment?", he wondered. To be left so uncertain of whether God really was, or whether God was only something inside his own head.
“这是惩罚的一部分吗？”，他心想。被留下，如此不确定上帝是否真的存在，还是上帝只是自己头脑中的某种东西。
After 700 years, when he told the story to himself, or heard it told by others, he felt nothing. He was too old to feel guilt, or remorse, or anything. He didn't even miss his brother anymore. He wanted nothing from God. He wanted nothing from the world. The world was what it was. He didn't need it to change. And in this way, he'd finally got his wish-- to be just like Abel. And then God let him die.
700年后，当他对自己讲述这个故事，或听到别人讲述时，他毫无感觉。他太老了，感觉不到内疚、懊悔或其他任何东西。他甚至不再想念他的弟弟了。他不需要上帝的任何东西。他不需要世界的任何东西。世界就是它现在的样子。他不需要它改变。就这样，他终于实现了他的愿望——变得和亚伯一样。然后上帝让他死了。
Jonathan Goldstein. He is the author of the novel Lenny Bruce Is Dead . Coming up, trying to help a bunch of people who don't really want your help, in what you really could call a biblical setting. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦。他是小说《莱尼·布鲁斯已死》的作者。接下来，试图帮助一群并不真正想要你帮助的人，在一个你可以真正称之为圣经背景的地方。就在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This is This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program of course we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Brother's Keeper. Stories of when it is hard to figure out exactly what you're supposed to do for others, exactly what your responsibility is.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《兄弟的看守》。关于当人们难以确定你到底应该为他人做些什么、到底什么是你的责任时，那些难以弄清楚的时刻的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, This Land is Your Land, This Land is My Land. Or Maybe Not. Nancy Updike has the story of a man who's tried to save a whole country. And how that's going.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，这片土地是你的土地，这片土地是我的土地。或者也许不是。南希·厄普代克讲述了一个试图拯救整个国家的人的故事。以及进展如何。
Most people are repelled by what they don't like. They avoid it. They don't want to see it, or hear it, or think about it. Dror Etkes spends all day looking at what he hates. Seeing more and more physical evidence of a future he dreads. Talking at length to people he vehemently disagrees with.
大多数人会对他们不喜欢的东西感到反感。他们会避开它。他们不想看到它、听到它或想到它。德罗尔·埃特克斯整天都在看着他憎恶的东西。看到越来越多他所恐惧的未来的实物证据。与他强烈反对的人长谈。
This, I think this is this place, most likely.
这个，我想最可能是这个地方。
What are you seeing?
你在看什么？
Two, three containers. Three mobile homes, I mean one Subaru. A huge manure. Two black water containers. And obviously, the beginning of settlement.
两、三个集装箱。三个移动房屋，我是说还有一辆斯巴鲁。一大堆肥料。两个黑色水箱。很明显，是定居点的开始。
Dror may be the only person in the world who knows, and is willing to discuss, the name and location of every Israeli settlement. Every shack, mobile home, housing cluster, bypass, road and town in the West Bank. In his rented Mitsubishi truck, he monitors settlements for the Israeli organization Peace Now. He gets calls from the American consulate requesting briefings and statistics. Israeli parliament members use his database. He's driven, he works alone, and he is not popular.
德罗尔可能是世界上唯一知道并愿意讨论每一个以色列定居点名称和位置的人。每一个窝棚、移动房屋、住宅区、旁路、道路和西岸的城镇。在他租来的三菱卡车里，他为以色列组织“现在和平”监视定居点。他接到美国领事馆要求简报和统计数据的电话。以色列议会议员使用他的数据库。他精力充沛，独自工作，而且并不受欢迎。
His single-minded mission is to expose a process that many people would like to keep quiet. Israeli prime minister Ariel Sharon told his cabinet in June that settlement building could continue, as long as it was discreet. "Don't celebrate," he said. "Just build." A settler spokesman agreed. "The less talk, and the less documentation, the better," he told an Israeli newspaper.
他一心一意的使命是揭露一个许多人想保持安静的过程。以色列总理阿里尔·沙龙在六月告诉他的内阁，定居点建设可以继续，只要它是谨慎的。“不要庆祝，”他说。“只管建造。”一位定居者发言人表示同意。“越少讨论，越少记录，越好，”他告诉一家以色列报纸。
Nearly half of the West Bank, 42%, is now controlled by Israeli settlers and the local and regional land councils the govern them. A political fact that makes any future peace agreement significantly more difficult. So several times a week, Dror gets into his truck, throws a bulletproof vest in the back, and does a reverse commute out into the West Bank to see what's going on.
近一半的西岸，42%，现在由以色列定居者以及管理他们的当地和区域土地委员会控制。一个政治事实，使任何未来的和平协议变得更加困难。因此，德罗尔每周几次跳进他的卡车，在后座扔上一件防弹背心，进行逆向通勤前往西岸，看看发生了什么。
We go up to a construction site on a hill about nine miles southeast of Jerusalem, with some men doing work on a bunch of new houses. Dror, who's about six feet tall and solid, strides over to the deeply tanned man in wraparound sunglasses who seems to be supervising the site.
我们来到耶路撒冷东南约九英里处的一个山上的建筑工地，有些人正在做关于一堆新房子的工作。德罗尔，大约六英尺高，身材结实，大步走到那个戴着环绕式太阳镜、晒得很黑、似乎在监督工地的男人面前。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
Do you speak English? Inglit?
你会说英语吗？英语？
[TRANSLATING] Yes, and I don't want to talk.
[翻译] 是的，我不想说话。
You don't want to talk?
你不想说话？
With this.
用这个。
The microphone.
麦克风。
Dror steers him away from the mike, and gets him to talk, no problem. He talked carpentry with him, he tells me as we're driving away. And in the process, found out everything he wanted to know.
德罗尔把他从麦克风旁引开，让他说话，没问题。他告诉我说，他们谈了木工，当我们开车离开时。在这个过程中，查到了他想知道的一切。
The information that I got is that they build 122 square meter houses. Going to build about five, six units altogether. And the buildings are for people living right now involves caravans here. But they consider it to be a neighborhood of [UNINTELLIGIBLE], which is here.
我得到的信息是，他们建造了122平方米的房子。总共要建造大约五个、六个单元。这些建筑是给现在住在这里的涉及大篷车的人住的。但他们认为这是[无法理解]的一个社区，它在这里。
A new settlement is like a new freckle. It can be hard to notice unless you're really looking for it. A mobile home appears on a hill somewhere in the West Bank. At first it's just up there, empty. Maybe it's next to a Palestinian village or city, maybe it isn't. A couple of people move in. They set up water tanks. A radio tower. Clear a rough road. Then bring in a few more mobile homes.
一个新的定居点就像一颗新的雀斑。除非你真的在看它，否则很难注意到。一个移动房屋出现在西岸的某个山上。起初它就在那儿，空着。也许它在巴勒斯坦村庄或城市旁边，也许不是。几个人搬了进去。他们架设了水箱。一个无线电塔。开辟了一条崎岖的道路。然后带进了更多的移动房屋。
Soon, there are enough people on the hill that they need defending. So soldiers are assigned to it. Electricity and water lines are run from the nearest, more established settlement. More people move in. Families, children. A school is started. Eventually the hills around the original hill need to be claimed in order to protect it.
很快，山上就有足够多的人需要防守。所以士兵被派往那里。电力和水管从最近的、更成熟的定居点接入。更多的人搬了进来。家庭，孩子。学校创办了。最终，为了保护最初的山丘，周围的山丘也需要被宣称所有。
Dror was born in 1968, ten months after the first settlement was created. When he was 15 years old, studying in a religious school in Jerusalem, there were 23,000 settlers in the West Bank and Gaza. When he was 21, and no longer religious, and was finishing his military service in an infantry combat unit, there were 72,000. When he was 28, and just back from years abroad trying to run away from Israel, it was 148,000.
德罗尔出生于1968年，在第一个定居点创建十个月后。当他15岁在耶路撒冷的宗教学校学习时，西岸和加沙有23,000名定居者。当他21岁，不再有宗教信仰，并结束了他在步兵作战部队的服兵役时，有72,000人。当他28岁，刚从国外试图逃离以色列的几年回来时，是148,000人。
When I came back to the country, I started quite soon after, to move on to the West Bank and to start to look for my own perspective. How actually things goes on there.
当我回到这个国家时，我很快就开始搬到西岸，开始寻找我自己的视角。那里到底发生了什么。
You started driving around the West Bank in--
你开始在西岸开车是在——
Two taxis. Palestinian taxis.
两辆出租车。巴勒斯坦出租车。
You just on your own initiative, when you got back? What were you looking for?
你回来时是出于你自己的主动吗？你在找什么？
Oh, speaking with people. And looking at the changes. You know, the West Bank had been dramatically changed during the nine years.
哦，和人说话。看着变化。你知道，西岸在九年间发生了巨大的变化。
The years Dror was away were the early years of the Oslo peace accords. A time when many Israelis saw a peaceful solution, two states for two peoples, as inevitable, and imminent. The growth of settlements during those years was not widely publicized or discussed. When Dror tried to tell his friends what he was seeing, they'd say, well we're giving it back anyway, so who cares if a few more houses are being built. And he'd say no, no, no, you don't understand. We're not preparing to give it back. We're preparing to stay.
德罗尔离开的那些年是奥斯陆和平协议的早年。那时许多以色列人认为和平解决方案，即“两国两族”，是不可避免且迫在眉睫的。那些年定居点的增长并没有被广泛宣传或讨论。当德罗尔试图告诉他的朋友他所看到的一切时，他们会说，好吧，反正我们要把它还回去，所以多盖几间房子又有什么关系呢。他会说不，不，不，你不明白。我们不是准备还回去。我们是准备留下来。
His friends' eyes would glaze over. They'd shrug. It infuriated him. He had no interest in turning his life into a political mission to save his country. He'd spent his years abroad avoiding Israelis, trying not to think about Israel. For a long time, he thought he'd never go back. Settlements were not something he'd ever intended to take on.
他朋友的眼神会变得呆滞。他们会耸耸肩。这让他感到愤怒。他毫无兴趣将他的生活变成拯救他国家的政治使命。他在国外度过的岁月都在避开以色列人，试图不去想以色列。很长一段时间里，他以为他永远不会回来。定居点从来不是他打算承担的事情。
At first when I came back to the country, consciously, I was keeping myself detached from this place in some ways. I tried to, at least, I think. I was not really able to do it. But somehow, I was trying to convince myself that I could live everywhere in the world. And when the time goes on, and I'm here longer, and especially over the last years. I must admit that, the settlers have made me, you know, I'm a born-again patriot. I feel that the settlers pushed me, shoved me to the corner, but I have to fight for this place. You know, fighting for our home. This is the settlers', their slogan. They're fighting for their homes. This is more or less what I feel right now.
起初当我回到这个国家时，有意识地，我在某些方面让自己与这个地方保持距离。我至少尝试过，我想。我真的没能做到。但不知何故，我试图说服自己，我可以生活在世界上的任何地方。随着时间的推移，我在这里呆得更久，特别是在过去的几年里。我必须承认，定居者让我，你知道，我是一个重生的爱国者。我感到定居者把我推到了墙角，但我必须为这个地方而战。你知道，为我们的家而战。这是定居者们的口号。他们为他们的家而战。这就是我现在或多或少的感觉。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号]
Hello?
喂？
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
Dror is calling a new settlement, pretending he wants to move there so he can get information about the place. He has an ever-changing repertoire of deceptions to get information. For a while he drove around the settlements posing as a cell phone technician, so he could ask a lot of intrusive questions. How many people live here? Oh, you'll need a couple of towers then, huh? What about that new road up there? Going to be some people up there, too? They'll need a cell tower. It worked well until a settler blew his cover by asking for ID, and then told all the others.
德罗尔正在给一个新的定居点打电话，假装想搬到那里，以便获取有关该地方的信息。他有一套不断变化的欺骗手段来获取信息。有一段时间，他开着车在定居点周围，冒充手机技术员，这样他就可以问很多侵入性的问题。这里住多少人？哦，那你需要几个塔，是吧？那上面的那条新路怎么样？上面也会有人吗？他们会需要一个信号塔。这很有效，直到一个定居者要求出示身份证拆穿了他的伪装，然后告诉了所有人。
When I drove with him, Dror told a lot of the people he talked to exactly who he was, and they spoke to him anyway. But he has no compunction about lying, elaborately, if need be, when he thinks it would help. Like with this phone call. Dror says he knows settler jargon, how to put them at ease. He grew up around settlers, in a religious family. He says he understands them, how they think and live. And on the phone, he finds out what he wants to know by playing a fully imagined alter-ego. Dror, the settler.
当我和他开车时，德罗尔告诉他交谈的许多人他到底是谁，他们还是和他说话了。但他认为在必要时进行复杂的撒谎没有任何顾虑，如果他认为这会有所帮助的话。就像这次通话一样。德罗尔说他知道定居者的术语，如何让他们放松。他在宗教家庭中长大，在定居者周围长大。他说他理解他们，他们如何思考和生活。在电话中，他通过扮演一个完全想象的另一个自我来找出他想知道的事情。德罗尔，定居者。
You know, father of four or five kids. And I was in army in a specific unit, where a lot of religious people are going. And I married a woman who does a certain thing. You know, she's a teacher. And I always admire the settlers. Of course, I'm religious, and I told them I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. But I'm a bit afraid, you know. I really want to do it, but I have to find the guts in me.
你知道，四个或五个孩子的父亲。而且我在军队的一个特定部队服役，很多宗教人士都去那儿。我娶了一个做特定工作的女人。你知道，她是一名教师。我一直钦佩定居者。当然，我是信教的，我告诉他们我是[无法理解]。但我有点害怕，你知道。我真的很想这样做，但我必须找到自己的胆量。
A settler spokesman once joked about Dror. His obsession shows a deep psychic tie to the land of Israel. In his previous incarnation, he must have been a settler. One of the side effects of Dror's job is that even though he disagrees with them, he now has more in common with settler activists than with the vast majority of Israelis.
一位定居者发言人曾开玩笑说德罗尔。他的痴迷显示了他与以色列土地深刻的心理联系。在他以前的化身中，他一定是一个定居者。德罗尔工作的副作用之一是，即使他不同意他们的观点，但他现在与定居者活动人士的共同点比与绝大多数以色列人的共同点更多。
Like settlers, he spends a lot of time in the West Bank, frustrated that the rest of Israel doesn't seem to know or care what's happening there. Like them, his position on the issue of settlements is at the core of his identity. He told me he can't be friends with anyone who disagrees with him about it. In fact, he said it's hard for him to relate to anyone who doesn't see the same things he does every day.
像定居者一样，他在西岸花了很多时间，对以色列其他人似乎不知道或不关心那里发生的事情感到沮丧。像他们一样，他对定居点问题的立场是他身份的核心。他告诉我，他无法与任何在这一点上不同意他的人做朋友。事实上，他说他很难与任何每天看不到和他一样东西的人产生共鸣。
We were leaving the settlement of Ariel when an orthodox man, who was asking every man who walked by whether he wanted to pray, called out to Dror. They had an exchange. Dror refused to pray, but he did it in a way that let the guy know he had a religious background. According to ancient Jewish law, minors, the deaf, and the retarded are exempt from following religious commands.
我们离开阿里尔定居点时，一个要求经过的每个男人是否想祈祷的东正教徒，对德罗尔喊道。他们进行了交流。德罗尔拒绝祈祷，但他以一种让那个人知道他有宗教背景的方式做到了。根据古代犹太法律，未成年人、聋哑人和智障者免于遵守宗教命令。
So I said to him, I am those three things. I am deaf, and I'm a minor, and I'm retarded. So I don't have to do it. So he realized immediately that I know something. It's not because I don't know. I know, and I don't do it, deliberately.
所以我对他说，我就是那三种人。我是聋子，我是未成年人，我是智障。所以我不需要这样做。所以他立刻意识到我懂点什么。不是因为我不知道。我知道，但我故意不做。
Do you do that to kind of needle them?
你这样做是为了刺痛他们吗？
Yeah, I like to provoke, like a provocation.
是的，我喜欢挑衅，像一种挑衅。
You like to provoke them.
你喜欢挑衅他们。
Yeah, I like to provoke them, yeah. Those guys are fundamentalists. They think what they're doing, you know, saving the world, redeeming the world-- bother me. I don't like it. I don't like people who are trying to convert other people.
是的，我喜欢挑衅他们，是的。那些家伙是原教旨主义者。他们认为他们正在做的，你知道，拯救世界，救赎世界——困扰我。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢那些试图改变别人的人。
You kind of are trying to convert people, though.
你某种程度上确实在试图改变别人。
[LAUGHTER] Am I? You're right. You're right. So I don't like people who try to convert, religiously, people.
[笑声] 是吗？你是对的。你是对的。所以我也不喜欢那些试图改变人们的宗教信仰的人。
You don't like the competition.
你不喜欢竞争。
I don't like the competition! Yeah, it's a good one. [LAUGHTER]
我不喜欢竞争！是的，这是一个好点。[笑声]
[CAR DOORS SLAM]
[车门猛关声]
Also like settler activists, he's always on the job. And like them, he sees his job as a constant effort to correct the misguided all around him. We picked up two 18 year old settler boys who were hitchhiking. He spent the first ten minutes of the ride milking them for information. Where do you live? He asked one. Ma'ale [UNINTELLIGIBLE], the kid answered. And how are things at Ma'ale [UNINTELLIGIBLE]? Praise the Lord, things are good, the kid said. Yeah?, said Dror. How many families are there? 89, 90, the kid said.
也像定居者活动人士一样，他总是忙于工作。像他们一样，他把他的工作视为一种不断的努力，以纠正他周围那些被误导的人。我们搭载了两个搭便车的18岁定居者男孩。他花了前十分钟的行程从他们那里获取信息。你住哪里？他问其中一个。马阿勒[无法理解]，孩子回答。马阿勒[无法理解]的情况怎么样？赞美主，情况很好，孩子说。是吗？德罗尔说。有多少个家庭？89，90，孩子说。
Once Dror had found out everything he wanted to know, he told them he monitored settlements for Peace Now, and one of the boys said, I'm curious about your outlook. Can you explain it to me? After saying he wasn't sure he had the energy to get into it with them, Dror began a half hour argument that got more and more heated and complicated. Until finally, one of the boy said plaintively, look, most of the country identifies with us. Forget about it, Dror said, shifting gears. He interrupted the main argument to explain to the kids, that in fact both of them, and Dror, are all in the same boat.
一旦德罗尔查明了他想知道的一切，他告诉他们他为“现在和平”监视定居点，其中一个男孩说，我对你的观点很好奇。你能跟我解释一下吗？在说他不确定是否有精力与他们讨论之后，德罗尔开始了一场持续了半小时的争论，变得越来越激烈和复杂。直到最后，其中一个男孩伤感地说，看，这个国家大多数人都认同我们。忘掉它吧，德罗尔说，换了档。他打断了主要争论，向孩子们解释说，事实上他们俩，和德罗尔，都在同一条船上。
"Forget about it. Most of the country doesn't give a dick-- pardon me, but I'm going to say this bluntly-- most of the country doesn't give a dick about what you say, or what I say. Both the settlers and Peace Now are tiny groups. The big fight between us, is who's able to capture broad public support. Not by getting people to identify with our ideology, because nobody gives a damn if God promised him some covenant with Abraham. This part of the land of Israel, or some other part. And unfortunately, no one gives a damn in this country about human rights either."
“忘掉它吧。这个国家大多数人根本不在乎——原谅我，但我会直言不讳地说出来——这个国家大多数人根本不在乎你怎么说，或者我怎么说。定居者和‘现在和平’都是很小的团体。我们之间的大战，是谁能够争取到广泛的公众支持。不是通过让人们认同我们的意识形态，因为没有人会关心上帝是否承诺了他与亚伯的某种契约。这部分以色列土地，还是其他部分。而且不幸的是，在这个国家没有人关心人权。”
Every American administration since 1967 has made some statement against settlements. Saying that they're contrary to the Geneva convention, the international law that governs occupying powers, and a serious obstacle to any peace agreement. President George Bush, in a speech that preceded the Road Map peace plan, said quote, "Israeli settlement activity in the occupied territories must stop."
自1967年以来，每一届美国政府都发表过反对定居点的声明。称它们违反了日内瓦公约，即管理占领国的国际法，并且是任何和平协议的严重障碍。乔治·布什总统在“路线图”和平计划之前的演讲中说，引用，“被占领土上的以色列定居点活动必须停止。”
Twice, first in 1978 and again in 1992, Israel and the US have come to explicit agreements to freeze settlement growth. Settlements have increased throughout. As they increase and multiply, it's hard to avoid certain questions. Where exactly is a Palestinian state going to fit? And if Israel really intends to withdraw from the West Bank and Gaza, to give up land for peace, why keep building?
两次，第一次在1978年，第二次在1992年，以色列和美国达成了明确的协议，冻结定居点增长。定居点始终在增加。随着它们增加和繁殖，很难避免某些问题。巴勒斯坦国到底要在哪里安身？如果以色列真的打算从西岸和加沙撤出，为了和平放弃土地，为什么要继续建造？
A few weeks ago, Dror testified before the US senate, the Near Eastern and South Asian Affairs subcommittee of the Foreign Relations Committee. A senator on tour in Israel a few months back met him, and invited him to speak about settlements and settlement growth.
几周前，德罗尔在美国参议院、外交关系委员会近东和南亚事务小组委员会前作证。几个月前在以色列访问的一位参议员见了他，并邀请他谈论定居点和定居点增长。
I think Dror's probably doing work that has already been done for him. And I think the American government with its satellite services could probably do it even better.
我认为德罗尔可能在做别人已经为他做过的工作。我认为美国政府及其卫星服务可能做得更好。
Israel Meidad grew up in Queens, and moved to the settlement of Shilo in 1981. He's debated Peace Now representatives many, many times. He's a settler spokesman.
以色列·梅达德在皇后区长大，1981年搬到了希洛定居点。他与“现在和平”代表争论过很多次。他是一位定居者发言人。
I'm sure they know exactly where the roads are, where the caravans are being placed. And for me, actually, he represents a very sort of unfortunate aspect of Zionism over the past hundred years. Where they have to run to the non-Jews in order to tell them what's going on. Its sort of an element of not accepting democracy. Democracy is, you decide. And we had a vote recently, and Mr. Sharon had over 65% of the vote.
我相信他们确切地知道道路在哪里，大篷车被安置在哪里。对我来说，实际上，他代表了过去一百年来犹太复国主义中一个非常不幸的方面。他们必须跑到非犹太人那里去告诉他们发生了什么。这是一种不接受民主的因素。民主是，你决定。我们最近进行了投票，沙龙先生获得了超过65%的选票。
I mean what he says is, look they invited me. And my main audience is Israel, is Israelis. That I'm gathering these numbers, and trying to put them out to Israel. And the Americans just happened to ask me. But my main audience is Israel. You're making a face.
我的意思是他说的是，看他们邀请了我。而我的主要受众是以色列，是以色列人。我收集这些数字，并试图把它们公之于众。而美国人只是碰巧问我。但我的主要受众是以色列。你在做鬼脸。
He's lying.
他在撒谎。
You don't think his main audience is Israel.
你不认为他的主要受众是以色列。
His main audience is the United States of America. I would say to him that, his political point of view has consistently lost out in a democratic form called elections in the state of Israel. The polls that have consistently been published about dismantling communities and taking Jews back, et cetera, like that, have always been, for peace, would you do this? Israelis would do anything for peace, to tell you the truth. But once the crunch comes, they decide otherwise, usually in elections. Polls are not elections. And Dror doesn't realize that. Dror thinks that his ideological position can be moved over onto the majority of the population. Consistently, over the past 37 years, that has not happened. I don't think it will.
他的主要受众是美利坚合众国。我会对他说，他的政治观点在以色列国称为选举的民主形式中一直处于失败地位。关于拆除社区和带回犹太人等等的民意调查一直发表，为了和平，你会这样做吗？为了和平，以色列人真的会做任何事，说实话。但一旦关键时刻到来，他们通常会在选举中做出不同的决定。民意调查不是选举。而德罗尔没有意识到这一点。德罗尔认为他的意识形态立场可以推广到大多数人口中。在过去的37年里，这种情况一直没有发生。我不认为会发生。
Where are we coming up to now?
我们现在要到哪里了？
We're entering a settlement, [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我们正在进入一个定居点，[无法理解]。
Dror believes that settlements will be dismantled and evacuated in his lifetime. He believes this, in spite of the fact that just in the time I've been interviewing him for this story, hundreds of new permits for houses in the West Bank have been issued. Eight outposts, some of them illegal, were granted the status of permanent communities by the government. A hundred million dollars was approved by the government to build houses in the occupied territories.
德罗尔相信，定居点在他有生之年会被拆除和疏散。尽管我为这个故事采访他的这段时间里，西岸已经发放了数百个新房子的许可证，但他仍然相信这一点。八个前哨基地，其中一些是非法的，被政府授予了永久社区的地位。一亿美元被政府批准用于在被占领土上建造房屋。
And a new incentive program was announced to attract young Israeli couples to settlements in the Jordan valley. Free rent for four years, plus full college tuition for one person in the couple. Over a hundred couples have signed up so far. Dror's optimism in the face of all this is especially shocking, given his personal experience. As we were driving through a block of settlements about nine miles east of Jerusalem, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] he announced suddenly--
而且宣布了一项新的激励计划，以吸引年轻的以色列夫妇到约旦河谷的定居点。四年免费租金，外加夫妇中一人全额大学学费。到目前为止，已经有超过一百对夫妇报名。鉴于他的个人经历，德罗尔面对这一切的乐观态度尤其令人震惊。当我们开车经过耶路撒冷以东约九英里处的一组定居点时，[无法理解]他突然宣布——
My sister live in Elon.
我姐姐住在埃隆。
Your sister lives here?
你姐姐住在这里？
Not here, in the other settlement, Elon.
不是这里，在另一个定居点，埃隆。
But in this block of settlements.
但在这一组定居点里。
Right.
对。
And, I mean, what does your sister think of what you do?
而且，我是说，你姐姐怎么看你的工作？
Well, she supports it, totally. She votes Israeli, she votes--
嗯，她完全支持。她投票给以色列人，她投票——
Come on!
得了吧！
Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is Israeli reality right now.
是啊，是啊，是啊。这就是现在的以色列现实。
So what do you mean, she supports it? I mean, it seems like your whole goal is to get her to move out of her house.
那你是什么意思，她支持？我的意思是，看起来你的整个目标是让她搬出她的房子。
Right. And my sister moved to this settlement eight months ago or so. They are living in a container. They're paying $100 rent. An apartment in Israel, in Jerusalem, would have the same size of their container, would cost perhaps five times more.
对。我姐姐大约八个月前搬到了这个定居点。他们住在一个集装箱里。他们付100美元租金。在以色列，在耶路撒冷，与他们的集装箱同样大小的公寓，可能要贵五倍。
So, did your sister talk to you about this before doing it? And say look, I'm going to do this?
那么，你姐姐在做这件事之前和你谈过吗？并且说看，我要这样做？
Yes, we had the hardest conversations before. We had very, very hard conversations about it. She just, I guess, concluded by saying that she would never build a house there at the settlement. And that she doesn't consider herself as an obstacle to peace. And if Israeli government would decide to evacuate those areas, of course she would never do anything against it. And nobody is living on this land anyhow.
是的，我们在那之前进行了最艰难的谈话。我们进行了非常非常激烈的关于它的谈话。她只是，我想，总结说她永远不会在那里盖房子。而且她不认为自己是和平的障碍。如果以色列政府决定撤离这些地区，她当然永远不会做任何反对它的事情。反正也没人住在这片土地上。
We headed up a rough dirt road near [UNINTELLIGIBLE] where two empty trailer homes sat on top of a hill, placeholders for an upcoming settlement to add to the block his sister lives in. We went inside one.
我们沿着[无法理解]附近的一条崎岖土路向上走，两辆空拖车房坐落在山顶上，作为即将到来的定居点的占位符，加入她姐姐居住的那一组。我们走进了其中一个。
So this is two bedrooms, a bathroom, and a sort of living room kitchen area.
所以这是两间卧室，一间浴室，还有一种客厅厨房区。
It's exactly the type of trailer which my sister has, where she live, I told you about before.
这正是和我姐姐住的一模一样的拖车，我之前跟你提起过。
This is the kind of trailer your sister lives in.
这是你姐姐住的那种拖车。
Quite, quite, quite similar. It's enough for young parents with one baby. I guess why my sister is refusing to see, this is what I told her is that, she is benefiting from extreme unjust political agenda. And this is what she's, just, closing her eyes to see. You know, claiming that she's going to Peace Now demonstration, one every four years, she's completing her duty. And if she votes the right party, once every four years, she's completing with her political responsibility. I think it's a very, very ignorant thing to say. I'm living with a consciousness. What you are doing privately in your life, how you live, where you shop, how you consume. Who you speak with, how do speak with. This is politics.
很，很，很相似。这对于有一名婴儿的年轻父母来说足够了。我想为什么我姐姐拒绝看到，这是我告诉她的，是她正在从极度不公正的政治议程中获利。而这就是她，只是，闭上眼睛不去看到。你知道，声称她去参加“现在和平”示威，每四年一次，她就在完成她的义务。如果她投票给正确的党派，每四年一次，她就在完成她的政治责任。我认为这是一种非常、非常无知的说法。我带着意识生活。你在私生活中做什么，你怎么生活，你在哪里购物，你怎么消费。你和谁说话，你怎么说话。这就是政治。
It sounds exhausting.
听起来很累人。
I look exhausted.
我看起来很累。
You don't look exhausted. On the contrary, you seem full of energy and pep.
你看起来不累。相反，你看起来充满了活力和干劲。
No, I'm very exhausted.
不，我非常累。
You feel exhausted?
你感到累？
Yes, exhausted. I feel exhausted, I don't feel that I'm as exhausted, that I'm ready to give up. And I don't. This is not what I'm saying. But living here in this country is an extremely exhausting thing. Living here consciously? If you are politically conscious and aware? It's an extremely exhausting thing. I have many friends who are living abroad, mostly in Europe. And I must admit that I'm envying them once in a while. They have much better life than I have. Much, much better.
是的，累。我感到累，我不觉得我已经累到准备放弃了。我不。这不是我在说的。但生活在这个国家是一件极其累人的事情。有意识地生活在这里？如果你在政治上有意识并意识到这一点？这是一件极其累人的事情。我有许多住在国外的朋友，大部分在欧洲。我必须承认，我偶尔会羡慕他们。他们有比我好得多的生活。多得多，多得多。
Patriotism is a kind of love. And like any other love, it can be unrequited. There's the patriot, Dror. He feels responsible to his country. Worries about it, has plans for it, feels devoted to it. And then there's the country itself. The patriot's fellow citizens. Who usually don't even notice what he's doing. And when they do notice, find it pathetic, or enraging, or unpatriotic.
爱国主义是一种爱。像任何其他爱一样，它可能是单相思。这就是爱国者，德罗尔。他感到对他的国家负责。担心它，有计划，感到奉献。然后是国家本身。爱国者的同胞们。他们通常甚至不注意他在做什么。当他们注意到时，发现它是可悲的、令人愤怒的或不爱国的。
Nancy Updike lives in Jerusalem. Her story's part of the Hearing Voices project, which gets funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting, and is online at hearingvoices.com.
南希·厄普代克住在耶路撒冷。她的故事是“倾听声音”项目的一部分，该项目从公共广播公司获得了资金，并在hearingvoices.com网站上。
[MUSIC - "DON'T FENCE ME IN" BY BING CROSBY]
[音乐 - 平·克劳斯贝的“别围住我”]
Act Three, Neighbor's Keeper. This is the story of a small town in Illinois. A farm town of 1,400 called Toulan. Where people usually look out for each other, help out when there's trouble. Except when it came to one problem that a few folks in town were facing. People in Toulon have different opinions about when this story begins, but everybody agrees on when it ends. March 22, 2002. Robert Kurson wrote about what happened that night, in an article that ended up in an anthology of best American crime reporting. This story gets a little grisly.
第三幕，邻居的看守。这是伊利诺伊州一个小镇的故事。一个有1400人的农场城镇，叫图伦。在那里，人们通常互相照应，有麻烦时互相帮助。除了当涉及到镇上几个人面临的一个问题时。图伦的人们对这个故事何时开始有不同的看法，但每个人都同意它何时结束。2002年3月22日。罗伯特·柯森写了那天晚上发生的事，在一篇最终出现在最佳美国犯罪报道选集中的文章中。这个故事有点可怕。
A new deputy was on duty in the town. A deputy named Adam Streicher, 23 year old guy, who was very new to the force. And wanted to do something useful.
一名新副警长在镇上执勤。一名叫亚当·斯特赖彻的副警长，23岁的家伙，刚加入部队。想做点有用的事。
He's looking for something to do.
他在找事情做。
He's looking for something to do. And so he rummaged around in the courthouse and in the station for any outstanding warrants that might need to be served. On this night he did find an outstanding warrant. One that was five months old, and that was to be served on a local resident named Curt Thompson. He didn't know Curt Thompson, and it was just for failure to pay some court costs and fines from a previous case. So he took the warrant, got in the deputy's squad car, and started to drive the short distance to Curt Thompson's house.
他在找事情做。所以他在法院和车站里到处翻找任何可能需要执行的未决逮捕令。那天晚上他确实发现了一份未决逮捕令。一份五个月前就有的，要在一个叫科特·汤普森的当地居民身上执行。他不认识科特·汤普森，这只是因为没有支付之前的案件中的一些法庭费用和罚款。所以他拿了逮捕令，上了副警长的警车，开始开车前往科特·汤普森家。
Curt Thompson came to the door, and was informed by Deputy Streicher that he had a warrant for Curtis Thompson. Thompson went back into his house, and came out with a shotgun. Lifted it up, and blew away Deputy Streicher's face and shoulder. Probably killed him instantly.
科特·汤普森来到门口，被斯特赖彻副警长告知他有一份针对柯蒂斯·汤普森的逮捕令。汤普森回到屋里，拿出一把霰弹枪出来。举起来，轰掉了斯特赖彻副警长的脸和肩膀。很可能让他当场死亡。
Then, Thompson took the deputy's pistol, jumped in the squad car, lights flashing, and set off to settle some scores. Just around the corner, he visits two neighbors that he'd been feuding with for years. And shoots them, right in front of their ten year old daughter.
然后，汤普森拿走了副警长的手枪，跳进警车，警灯闪烁，出发去结算一些旧账。就在拐角处，他拜访了两个他已经争斗多年的邻居。并在他们十岁的女儿面前，射杀了他们。
Maybe a half-minute drive from there, Thompson rams into another neighbor on the street that he doesn't like, but the guy gets away. Thompson goes looking for yet another neighbor he has a grudge against, but that guy's not home.
也许从那里开车半分钟，汤普森撞上了街上他不喜欢的另一个邻居，但那家伙逃走了。汤普森去寻找他怀恨在心的另一个邻居，但那家伙不在家。
What Robert Kurson found, digging into old court records, talking to all sorts of people in Toulon, was that this man, Curt Thompson, had been getting into all sorts of angry episodes and disputes with various neighbors for 30 years.
罗伯特·柯森挖掘旧的法庭记录，与图伦的各种各样的人交谈后发现，这个叫科特·汤普森的人，30年来一直与各种邻居发生各种愤怒的事件和纠纷。
You could get too close to him at the grocery. You could drive too close to him. Very, very minor, petty things that third or fourth graders might complain about in grade school. In one case, I think someone's laundry blew on to his property. And that marked the offender for vendetta for years.
你在杂货店和他靠得太近。你开车离他太近。非常、非常微小、琐碎的事情，三四年级的学生可能在小学里抱怨。在一个案例中，我想有人洗的衣服吹到了他的财产上。这标志着侵犯者多年来受到报复。
Well, Curt began, as we say, casing my house.
好吧，正如我们所说，科特开始盯着我的家。
This is Rick Collins, of Toulon.
这是图伦的里克·柯林斯。
Driving by slowly, and watching what I would be doing at my home. And checking on my dog, and that sort of stuff. And giving me the eye, glaring at me.
慢慢开车经过，看着我在家里做什么。检查我的狗，诸如此类的事情。给我眼色，瞪着我。
Was it intimidating, the glaring?
那个瞪眼让人感到恐吓吗？
To a degree. Because Curt had a reputation for swinging first and asking questions later, that sort of thing. It was well known that he had a very bad temper.
在某种程度上。因为科特以先动手后问问题而闻名，诸如此类的事情。众所周知，他脾气非常暴躁。
Yeah.
是啊。
That he could become violently angry.
他可能会变得非常愤怒。
Rick Collins got on Curt Thompson's bad side when Curt's dog bit a child who lived nearby. At the time, Rick was the mayor of Toulon. And he sent out the city marshall, the policeman who is on the city payroll, to do a routine call about the incident. Check that the dog was vaccinated, and properly registered. It led to some fines and a little bit of trouble for Curt Thompson.
里克·柯林斯是在科特的狗咬了住在附近的一个孩子时惹上科特·汤普森的。当时，里克是图伦的市长。他派出了城市执行官，即领城市工资的警察，去处理关于这起事件的常规电话。检查狗是否接种了疫苗，并正确注册。这导致了科特·汤普森的一些罚款和一点小麻烦。
Somewhere in this period, there was a retirement party nearby. About seven miles from town, just over the county line in the next county. And I had stopped by to wish the retiree a happy retirement. Curt and his wife were there. And in the process of walking past their table, I stopped and said hello Curt, and hello Virginia, just as I've said it to you.
在这一时期的某个地方，附近有一个退休派对。离镇约七英里，就在县界线的下一个县。我顺便去祝退休人员退休快乐。科特和他的妻子也在那儿。在经过他们的桌子时，我停下来打招呼，科特好，弗吉尼亚好，就像我刚才跟你说的一样。
And as it came to pass, Curt followed me out. And began shouting and yelling obscenities at me, and when we reached a staircase, he basically hit me from behind, pushing me down a flight of stairs. And I wasn't injured, I caught myself without tumbling. And got to the bottom, and I thought, boy, this is not good. I got outside and drove home. And at that point, I think I did turn it in.
事情发生了，科特跟着我出来。并开始对我大喊大叫淫秽词汇，当我们到达楼梯时，他基本上从后面打我，把我推下楼梯。我没有受伤，我抓住自己没有翻滚。到了底部，我想，男孩，这不好。我到了外面开车回家。在那一点上，我想我确实报告了。
I called the sheriff and reported what had happened. And they were not interested. They said well, it happened in another county, so, not to worry. So I called the district attorney of that county, because, I thought well, this isn't really good, pushing public officials down a flight of stairs. And that state's attorney wasn't too interested in pursuing it, and that's kind of where it lay.
我给警长打电话报告发生了什么。他们不感兴趣。他们说好吧，它发生在另一个县，所以，不用担心。所以我给那个县的地区检察官打了电话，因为我想好吧，这真不好，把公共官员推下楼梯。而那个州检察官对追究它不太感兴趣，这就是它留下的地方。
In fact, this was the pattern around town for decades. People would try to get the police and courts to take action. But either they wouldn't pick up the case, or if they did, Curt Thompson would just get a slap on the wrist. Some of his actions were shocking. He threatened the sheriff, repeatedly. Told him he'd bury him. Ran him off the road. And only ended up with $111 fine, and 100 hours of community service.
事实上，这是几十年来镇上的模式。人们会试图让警察和法院采取行动。但要么他们不会接案子，要么如果他们接了，科特·汤普森也只是受到轻微的惩罚。他的一些行动令人震惊。他多次威胁警长。告诉他他会埋了他。把他赶出路。最后只得到111美元罚款，和100小时社区服务。
The couple that he eventually murdered, Jim and Janet Giesenhagen, he'd been feuding with for over a decade. He'd circle around their house in his truck at 8:00 in the morning, when their daughter was just leaving for school. They started driving her, even though the school was just a few blocks away. One day Thompson told them that he'd kill them. They got a judge to issue an order of protection, ordering him to stay away. He didn't.
他最终谋杀的那对夫妇，吉姆和珍妮特·吉森哈根，他已经与他们争斗了十多年。他早上8点开车在他们房子周围转圈，当他们的女儿刚要出门去学校时。他们开始开车送她，尽管学校只有几个街区远。有一天汤普森告诉他们他会杀了他们。他们让法官签发了保护令，命令他远离。他没有。
In the next days, there was Thompson in his truck, glaring.
在接下来的日子里，汤普森在卡车里，瞪着眼睛。
Again, reporter Robert Kurson.
再次是记者罗伯特·柯森。
And so Giesenhagen, believing that all he needed was evidence of this violation of the order of protection, and that would finally, hopefully, put Thompson away, attaches a video camera to his home and tapes Thompson breaking, repeatedly, these orders of protection. According to what I was told, these tapes were turned over to authorities, and nothing happened.
所以吉森哈根，认为他所需要的只是这个违反保护令的证据，那最终，希望，能把汤普森抓起来，在家安装了一个摄像机并录下了汤普森反复违反这些保护令。据我所知，这些录像带被移交给了当局，什么也没发生。
I watched every minute, every second of those videotapes. There was nothing on there that you could use as evidence to substantiate bringing in a criminal charge.
我看了那些录像带的每一分钟，每一秒。上面没有任何东西可以用来作为证据来证实提起刑事指控。
Richard Schwind is with the Illinois attorney general's office, and worked on the murder case against Curt Thompson.
理查德·施温德在伊利诺伊州总检察长办公室工作，致力于处理科特·汤普森的谋杀案。
The tapes that we were given did not show a violation. It showed that Mr. Thompson would drive on the public way behind the Giesenhagen home. But there was nothing to show that would substantiate any violation.
我们收到的录像带没有显示违规。它显示汤普森先生会在吉森哈根家后面的公共道路上开车。但没有任何东西显示可以证实任何违规行为。
So if he was just driving through this alley, that wouldn't constitute a violation.
所以如果他只是穿过这条小巷，那不会构成违规。
No. He had a right to be on a public way. If he went on to the Giesenhagen property, that would be a different story. Mr. Thompson knew how far to push the envelope, and how far to go before violating the law.
不。他有权利在公共道路上。如果他进入了吉森哈根的财产，那将是另一个故事。汤普森先生知道在违反法律之前要把界限推到多远。
Sure enough, says the former mayor, Rick Collins. But he believes that when he was mayor, there were clear opportunities for Toulon to do more to stop Curt Thompson. And especially for the town policemen, to enforce rules against Curt Thompson. But the policemen, he says, wouldn't take action.
果然，前市长里克·柯林斯说。但他认为当他还是市长时，图伦有明显的机会采取更多行动来阻止科特·汤普森。特别是镇上的警察，执行反对科特·汤普森的规则。但他说是警察，他说，不会采取行动。
There had been complaints previously about Curt's wood pile, and the trash around his house, and abandoned cars. That sort of thing. And our city marshall wasn't too interested in pursuing anything with Curt.
以前曾有关于科特的木柴堆、他房子周围的垃圾和废弃汽车的投诉。诸如此类的事情。我们的城市执行官对追踪任何关于科特的事情不太感兴趣。
Why?
为什么？
Well, you know. I think that I should preface this by saying, we've all got blood on our hands. All of us should have pressed the issue.
嗯，你知道。我想我应该在 preface 这一点时说，我们所有人的手上都有血。我们所有人都应该推动这个问题。
Do you remember having conversations with the marshall, with the sheriff, with the police? Where you'd say, you know, we've got to enforce this?
你还记得与执行官、警长、警察进行过对话吗？你说，你知道，我们必须执行这个？
Yes. I did say, we have to do something about this, it's only going to get worse.
是的。我确实说，我们必须对此做点什么，它只会变得更糟。
And what'd they say?
他们怎么说？
They said, don't worry about it. It's our problem.
他们说，不用担心。这是我们的问题。
Hm.
嗯。
There was no appetite for enforcing any ordinances in regard to Curt. This was one of the reasons I resigned. If you can't control your city employees and the city council is not willing to back you up, then you really have no business being the mayor.
对于关于科特的任何条例没有执行的欲望。这是我辞职的原因之一。如果你不能控制你的城市雇员，而市议会不愿意支持你，那你确实没有理由当市长。
See I wonder, even if you all had enforced all these things-- the level of punishment that Curt Thompson would have gotten would have been pretty minimal.
看我很好奇，即使你们所有人都执行了所有这些事情——科特·汤普森得到的惩罚水平也会非常少。
Oh yeah.
哦是的。
And so in the end, would it have actually forestalled a big tragedy happening like what happened?
所以最后，它是否真的会阻止像发生那样大的悲剧？
Yes I believe it would have, Ira. It's been my observation that whether one is a schoolteacher, or a policeman, or regardless of your position, even in the unemployer. When you have rules, and the rules are enforced unequivocally, when people know that certain actions bring certain results. They tend not to violate the rules. And Curt is no different than the rest of us. And when an individual feels that they are above or immune, or can violate law with impunity, they will do so. And they'll continue to do it with increasing severity until something happens.
是的，我相信会，艾拉。根据我的观察，无论是一个老师，还是一个警察，或者不管你的职位，甚至在雇主那里。当你有了规则，而规则得到明确执行时，当人们知道某些行动带来某些结果时。他们倾向于不违反规则。科特和我们其他人没什么不同。当一个人感到他们高于或免于，或可以免受惩罚地违反法律时，他们就会这样做。他们会以越来越严重的方式继续这样做，直到某事发生。
It's interesting to hear. Like you feel very confident that if lines had been drawn early on, it would never have gotten to this point.
这很有趣。像你非常有信心如果早点划定界限，它就不会发展到这一点。
Without a doubt. Absolutely without a doubt. There's no question in my mind whatsoever.
毫无疑问。绝对毫无疑问。我心中毫无疑问。
Rick Collins says that he tried to get the six members of the Toulon city council to act, to force the town policemen to go after Curt Thompson, there was so little interest, they never even came to a vote. The Toulon policeman that he wanted to take action is named Bob Taylor. He's still the marshall in Toulon. And he says that he has no regrets about how he handled Curt Thompson.
里克·柯林斯说，他试图让图伦市议会的六名成员采取行动，强迫镇上的警察去追赶科特·汤普森，由于兴趣太少，他们甚至没有投票。他想采取行动的图伦警察叫鲍勃·泰勒。他仍然是图伦的执行官。他说他不后悔他处理科特·汤普森的方式。
Curt Thompson was not like other people. Or at least most people in a small town. He was very anti-social. He was just a guy that I think aggressive action may have just sped things up, not headed them off.
科特·汤普森不像其他人。或者至少不像一个小镇上的大多数人。他非常反社会。他只是一个家伙，我认为积极的行动可能只会加快事情的进程，而不是阻止它们。
You think aggressive action would have had the opposite effect from what the mayor is saying?
你认为积极的行动会产生与市长所说的相反的效果吗？
That would be my belief, yes.
那会是我的信念，是的。
You think aggressive action actually would have set him off?
你认为积极的行动实际上会引发他？
Right. He'd have probably been as defiant as he normally was. Probably would have pushed things to the limit.
对。他可能一直像往常一样反抗。可能已经把事情推到了极致。
Normally, when somebody's in trouble in Toulon, people step in to help. When Dean Greave got sick a few weeks ago, some neighbors harvested his corn and beans. When a big wind storm knocked out power for a few days this summer, people showered in each other's houses, helped out as they could. Every few weeks, there are all sorts of benefit suppers, and dances, and auctions for people who are sick or doing badly. Where usually 100 to 300 people show up. This, remember, in a town of 1,400.
通常，当图伦的某个人有麻烦时，人们会介入帮忙。当迪恩·格里夫几周前生病时，一些邻居收获了他的玉米和大豆。当夏天一场大风暴导致停电几天时，人们在彼此的家里洗澡，尽可能地帮忙。每隔几周，都有各种各样的福利晚餐、舞会和拍卖会，为生病或境况不佳的人准备。通常有100到300人出席。记住，这是一个有1400人的城镇。
With Curt Thompson, the community collectively decided to avoid the problem.
对于科特·汤普森，社区集体决定避开这个问题。
Jim Nowlan edits the town paper, the Stark County News. He says maybe a half dozen people were being harassed by Curt Thompson at any given time. But it just wasn't the sort of thing you could hold a benefit for. It wasn't clear exactly what to do.
吉姆·诺兰编辑镇报，《斯塔克县新闻》。他说也许有半打人当时一直被科特·汤普森骚扰。但这根本不是那种你可以举办福利的事情。不清楚到底该做什么。
I think if you were to do a movie about a story like this, there would probably be some Jimmy Stewart type who would become so aroused, maybe at the lack of action taken by others, that he would simply, you know, carrying a torch, gather the townsfolk in the square and march on Curt Thomson's house. And simply demand that he come out and apologize, and commit never to do anything like that again. But that didn't happen.
我想如果你要拍一部关于这种故事的电影，可能会有一些吉米·斯图尔特类型的人物变得非常被激怒，也许是因为其他人缺乏行动，他会简单地，你知道，带着火炬，在广场聚集镇民并游行到科特·汤普森家。并简单地要求他出来道歉，并承诺永远不再做那样的事。但这并没有发生。
Though Jim Nowlan sounds a little bit like Jimmy Stewart as he says all this, there was no Jimmy Stewart in town to end the story that way. And if anything, the scenario that people in Toulon sometimes talked about for Curt Thompson is a much darker one. Here's Robert Kurson, the reporter.
虽然吉姆·诺兰在说这一切时听起来有点像吉米·斯图尔特，但镇上没有吉米·斯图尔特以那种方式结束故事。如果有的话，图伦的人们有时谈论科特·汤普森的方案是一个更黑暗的方案。这是记者罗伯特·柯森。
Many people in the aftermath, thought that someone should have gone and taken care of him physically.
事后很多人认为，应该有人去从身体上照顾他。
Wow, people actually said this to you?
哇，人们真的对你说过这个？
Yes. That vigilante justice was the only option remaining.
是的。私刑是唯一剩下的选择。
In the story that you wrote, you tell the story at one point of the town of Skidmore, Missouri in 1981. And they faced a similar kind of figure, a guy named Ken McElroy, who got into all sorts of feuds. Talk about what happened in that case.
在你写的那个故事里，你在某一点讲述了1981年密苏里州斯基德莫尔镇的故事。他们面临着类似的人物，一个叫肯·麦克尔罗伊的家伙，他卷入了各种争斗。谈谈那个案例中发生了什么。
It was a very similar set-up. The town, like Toulon, watched out for each other. They took care of each other. This guy rode into town and started terrorizing, in much the same way that Curt Thompson did. He kept vendettas going. He was violent. And he seemed above the law.
这是一个非常类似的设置。城镇，像图伦，互相照应。他们互相照顾。这个家伙骑车进镇并开始像科特·汤普森一样进行恐怖活动。他保持着世仇。他很暴力。他看起来高于法律。
The reaction of the people in Skidmore was different than it was in Toulon. They surrounded his truck in broad daylight, 30 or 40 of them, and murdered him. Someone shot him. 30 or 40 witnesses. The police came in to solve the murder. Nobody would say who fired the shots. Nobody would talk. Everybody knew who did it. To this day, that case in Missouri remains open and unsolved. Nobody will speak.
斯基德莫尔人们的反应与图伦不同。他们在光天化日之下包围了他的卡车，30或40个人，杀了他。有人开了枪。30或40名目击者。警察进来解决谋杀案。没人会说谁开了枪。没人会说话。每个人都知道是谁做的。直到今天，密苏里州的那个案例仍然是开放和未解决的。没人会说话。
It's funny, the idea of, you know, we should look out for each other, we should be each other's keeper. We usually think of it as driving us towards acts of kindness. You know when somebody's sick, when somebody's in trouble. It's odd to think of it as being an impulse that would actually drive a group of people to kill somebody.
有趣的是，你知道，我们应该互相照顾，我们应该是彼此的看守。我们通常认为它推动我们做出善行。你知道当某人生病，某人有麻烦时。很难想到它是一种实际上会驱使一群人杀掉某人的冲动。
Well everybody in this town agreed on one thing. They could either hope that nothing bad happened, and just continue to live with the problem. Or, blank. The town of Skidmore, Missouri filled in the blank. The town of Toulon was not able to fill in that blank.
好吧，这个镇上的每个人都同意一件事。他们要么希望没发生什么坏事，继续和这个问题生活在一起。或者，空白。密苏里州斯基德莫尔镇填补了空白。图伦镇没能填补那个空白。
Of course, if you're in a situation where your only choices are, do nothing, or vigilante murder, things can't get much worse. Chris Thompson went to trial for his three murders. These days he sits on death row, where, if Illinois lifts its moratorium on the death penalty someday, the people of Illinois will finally fill in that blank.
当然，如果你处于一种选择只有，什么都不做，或者私刑谋杀的情况下，事情不会变得更糟。克里斯·汤普森因他的三起谋杀案受审。这些天他坐在死囚牢房，如果伊利诺伊州有一天取消死刑暂停，伊利诺伊州的人民最终会填补那个空白。
Our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane [? Kolumbiski ?] and Starlee Kine, our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey [? Diltz ?].
我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格，简[？科伦比斯基？]和斯塔莉·凯恩，我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯尔西[？迪尔茨？]提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows are free, or now, you can buy CDs , do you hear me, CDs. Or you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com. This American life is driven by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目，或者现在，你可以购买CD，你听到我说了吗，CD。或者你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，在那里他们有公共广播节目，畅销书，甚至是纽约时报，都在audible.com。这个美国生活由国际公共广播电台驱动。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds me all the time, "Pardon me, but I'm going to say this bluntly. Most of the country doesn't give a dick about what you say, or what I say." And yet, we'll be back next week, with more stories of this American life.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他一直提醒我，“原谅我，但我会直言不讳地说出来。这个国家大多数人根本不在乎你怎么说，或者我怎么说。” 然而，下周我们会回来，带着更多这个美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。